hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report in paris
hey you know we've
moved on from just
printing lots of money and incurring
lots of debt for dumb reasons
to printing lots of money and incurring
lots of debt for extraordinarily dumb
reasons
stacy
right
well you know
france is a place that knows revolution
based on inflation and inflation prices
i remember it all came down to let them
eat cake when the food prices were too
high
well
today we're in more inflation around the
world and just we've been covering this
for the last few months now with this
stagflation emerging but here's some
more shocking information first we'll go
back to the us with these first two the
national average rent and multi-family
buildings i.e apartment buildings rose
10.3 percent from a year earlier to 1539
the first double-digit rise in the data
sets history from erd data over the past
10 years the average pace of growth has
been 2
but it's now 10
well as we've been saying the purchasing
power of the fiat money u.s dollar
has always been
falling
uh it was kept away from utter collapse
by
transporting all of america's
manufacturing capacity to china for a
while but that trick is finished now so
now all this money printing is just
causing the purchasing power to
to fall dramatically that's called
inflation and so people's quality of
life is now deteriorating rapidly
because of
money printing which is something that
doesn't have to be the case they don't
have to do it they don't have to print
the money they do so because they're
lazy and they're corrupt remember what
we've seen is extraordinary amounts of
money printing
not only from the central banks printing
credit but stimulus coming from the
governments
to the pocketbooks of americans
as we've covered a lot of americans
actually earned a lot more
unemployed and locked down at home but
importantly there were no expansion in
goods and services right it's only what
china was the only economy left standing
in the entire past year and a half
so
whatever they were able to produce and
ship importantly there's only so many
ships in the world right and the ports
are only so big and can handle so many
ships so
you're seeing that a huge amount of cash
meet a limited supply u.s producer price
inflation jumps 8.3
in august the largest year-on-year
increase on record remember jay powell
the fed
the treasury
janet yellen she also said like this is
transitory don't worry it's going to be
fine we hope so everybody hopes so but
right now the numbers look biggest ever
on history of the united states anyway
of course europe has had some big
hyperinflations in their past
right and
they
categorically
state that the problem is deflation jay
powell and janet yellen and policymakers
and politicians overtly
lie
in in a way that is um
disingenuous
you know it's uh they call it deflation
people's prices for stuff energy and
food is going up
but they say that's deflation so
um
again when you have public officials who
are who are allowed to simply state in
categorically falsehoods like this
unchecked then you know that's part of
the problem
of course germany is always the worst
one in terms of uh nobody wants
inflation there right
and
however
good morning from germany where
inflation pressures keep rising
germany's wholesale prices jump
12.3 percent
year on year in august versus 11.3
percent in june this was the highest
monthly annual rate of change since
october of 1974 after the first oil
crisis and you could see the chart there
looking up pretty steep over in germany
right when mario draghi was running the
european central bank which is really
the leftover from the german central
bank to bundesbank
everyone thought that all the
quantitative easing and money printing
would end it wouldn't go into europe
they wouldn't because they know the the
tragedy of inflation in the 1930s led to
the rise of uh totalitarianism and the
death of millions and they said you know
we're not going to let hyperinflation
come in but but draghi and the european
central bank did it anyway so they
clearly uh did not learn any of the
lessons of the 1930s they're trying to
in fact to repeat them by hyperinflating
their currency by rewarding the worst
it's a cachistocracy you've got out of
control bureaucrats who are acting
in
as lunatics and they're being rewarded
as such
right well it's kind of the entropy of
the system right this
debt
saturation happens and
at a certain point you could only pile
so much more debt
on top of the old promises
that will never be met and at a certain
point
you reach a generation whether it's
millennial or z
that
you've brought forward all of their
consumption over the previous 50 years
and
there becomes a moment of collision
of the generations of societies of food
prices so
we could be at that now
you never know it usually happens slowly
and then suddenly
and what are they going to do the ecb
has started to taper a little bit they
were purchasing 80 billion euros per
month of assets now they're down to
between 60 and 70 billion but they need
more so let's look at what's happening
in the euro zone in terms of how they're
going to keep on feeding this ponzi
because max you've always said you can't
taper a ponzi right
e
to propose
exempting green bonds from deficit and
debt limit calculations christine
lagarde over at the ecb was saying like
we
okay
the ecb is tapering but we need some
more money right we need fiscal support
i the nation states within the eurozone
need to uh increase how much they're
spending on stimulus and domestically so
remember
with europe the way it's set up the
structure of the monetary union is that
eu budget rules created in 1997 and
changed three times since then set
limits on government borrowing
to protect the value of the euro they
require eu countries to cut debt below
60 percent of gdp and annual deficits to
below 3 percent of gdp or face fines
while the rules were temporarily
suspended in 2020 to give governments
more scope to fight the coronavirus
pandemic they are due to be reinstated
in 2023
and max they want to
change that again obviously in 2023 they
won't be able to unwind this debt
because the data on that according to
the commission the 19 countries that
share the euro will have a budget
deficit of 8 percent of gdp this year up
from 7.2 percent last year while their
public debt is set to reach
102.4 percent of gdp there is no way
this number can ever
again drop back to 60 percent well we we
know from the episode of greece that
they uh shirked the rules of debt the
gdp to fraudulently allow greece into
the eu so that goldman sachs and the
leadership of greece could attack it
with credit default swaps and make
billions of dollars on its destruction
so they don't respect laws they write
laws as befits their need to steal it's
called larceny
it's also called entropy and the
inevitable immutable
future outcome of any debt based system
is always going to collapse in an
avalanche of bad debts always it doesn't
matter what sort of tricks what sort of
rules what sort of think tanks say what
sort of ideas they come up with it
there's no magic solution to it other
than bitcoin yeah exactly but you could
slow the entropy by having someone other
than a crook run the system so the way
uh these bureaucratic systems work is um
it's think tanks economists commissions
that come up with these ideas uh we
didn't think of this but we'll allow it
because these think tanks of very smart
people came up with these ideas so the
green golden rule
and the mmt argument are being presented
on one hand the zero hedge article
points out a think tank has come up with
a green golden rule excluding
net green investment from the fiscal
indicators used to measure fiscal rule
compliance is the most promising option
to address this tension that this
tension being uh the deficit and the
debt levels so the debt levels are over
100 to gdp
which um is obviously the the point
where the imf itself is always saying uh
that's the danger zone when a country is
likely to default so because of all the
stimulus all the
lockdowns the shutdowns that are ongoing
it's impossible to get back down to the
eu rules from here
especially as all these variants emerge
so the green golden rule remember
it was i think it was gordon brown in
the uk who came up with the golden rule
right that uh you could only borrow to
invest that was the only thing that the
government would do to borrow to invest
so here it's the green golden rule
and the other thing they point out is
that predictably some eu officials argue
the rules reflect past realities when
debt was relatively low and interest
rates were relatively high as opposed to
the high debt and very low or even
negative cost of borrowing now which
makes high debt more sustainable this is
also known as the mmt argument
right the the point of tension
or the what they're running up against
is the respect for human rights
money printing violates human rights
christine lagarde
is violating human rights by
killing
the purchasing power
of the hard-earned money of the people
living in europe who therefore are
having trouble surviving
and
she's doing what every money printer in
the history has always done
justified
her abuse of human rights
by calling it something else
it's newspeak it's orwellian newspeak
because she has an expensive haircut and
nice clothes doesn't mean she's any less
of an authoritarian disaster i saw
the german newspapers
had
images of the ecb's balance sheet
because that's hit all-time highs i
think it's 8.65 trillion euros
um
a greater percentage of gdp than the u.s
fed the u.s fed is under 40 percent
which is still
the biggest in history in the u.s right
in the of the u.s fed um
and in the eurozone it's double that so
you know it's over 80 percent of debt to
gdp on the on the balance sheet of the
ecb so they're piling on that
debt for sure and
how it ever gets unwound
amidst an ongoing
lockdown
and coveted sort of crisis
who knows
well i think the hague is still up and
running
the court of human rights uh i think
this is where christine lagarde is
headed uh when we finally do an
accounting uh and and understand that
this was a massive fraud and that people
were
absolutely
disenfranchised to benefit a few
um
career criminals all right we're gonna
take a break and when we come back much
more coming your
way welcome back to the kaiser report
i'm max keiser time now to turn to
pierre noisa he's the ceo and founder of
premium he's been writing some brilliant
stuff on energy and
money but first pierre let's do a little
look back in history here you were at
the very first bitcoin conference as we
were max and stacy uh took place in
prague in 2011.
uh you're a bitcoin og for sure
uh you've flown us here to paris to
celebrate your company's 10th
anniversary it sounds like it's going to
be an exciting event
but tell us briefly about premium
and and what you've seen over the past
10 years
well that's uh
premium is the first one of the very
first bitcoin exchanges in the world um
we were number three i believe after
mtgox and btc back then
uh and we offered uh people to exchange
bitcoin for euros so that also was new
because the others were dealing in
dollar
uh and the other two disappears
so i've disappeared so we are we are
left as the most uh
the oldest the longest running bitcoin
exchange in the world uh yeah it's been
quite all right and um
i'd say uh it's been basically about uh
raising frictions with the you know the
the legacy system with the euro
banking system yeah let's talk about
that for a second because right now it
seems like the legacy banking system is
finally figuring out the threat
that bitcoin poses at first they treated
it like
a novelty magic internet money but now
with el salvador taking it on as legal
currency ukraine legalizing other
countries following suit it seems like
the revolution is really really
happening it is it is happening and
there is nothing they can do about it so
all they can do is delaying delaying
tactics and uh
trying to uh you know
make
spread further about it so people don't
invest in bitcoin uh
still think it's as you said magic money
internet money as if the euro was not
magic money yeah good point the fiat
money is really just the printed out of
thin air i keep saying the euro is just
a
stable coin uh using an obsolete
technology that's uh that's that's what
the euro is today right and um people
start realizing it and and obviously the
the incumbents are just trying to uh um
draw their attention to something else
like uh energy uh as if there was an
energy issue with bitcoin which
doesn't exist yeah we're going to get
into that now of course your background
is an engineering i notice a lot of
people who stay in bitcoin the longest
have backgrounds in engineering it's
what they what attracts them to this
project and um so speaking about the
engineering side of bitcoin let's talk
about the proof of work algorithm so
briefly describe to the audience what it
is and how important it is to bitcoin
uh yeah the algorithm
of the protocol of bitcoin is designed
to monetize uh energy
uh and uh
the economics are such that it's about
monetizing energy surpluses that is the
cheapest possible energy so it provides
some kind of floor price for the energy
because miners are incentivized to go
for the cheapest one otherwise they are
just not profitable
uh compared to their their competitors
um so it's a global system therefore
there is a global arbitrage for uh the
cheapest uh energy price
um
and that's that's how the the bitcoin
protocol is designed
so it's typically a
competition for gold because gold is
also proof of energy when i get a piece
of gold a coin gold coin uh it's in fact
a proof of energy that the energy that's
been required to extract it mint it uh
get it to the place of the transaction
etc so that's a stock of energy and
energy comes in two forms basically as a
flow or as a stock
and as a flow it's what people call
renewable energy so it's solar
electricity uh
potential energy also energy you can't
see but that's there and um stocks is
basically any finished good is a stock
of energy a piece of gold is a stock of
energy
we are a stock of energy um and stocks
of energy like that are also open
systems from you know a thermodynamic
standpoint from the standpoint of the
science of energy we are all
receiving energy and energy flows
through source right so just uh take a
look at the energy picture 170 000
terawatts of energy per year we use here
on planet earth less than one tenth of
one percent of that is dedicated to
bitcoin and that energy is generally
discarded energy you know uh roughly a
third of all energy usage in the world
is or or generation is is discarded uh
because it takes a lot of energy to move
energy and it
is wasted in transmission
so it's not so much about bitcoin using
energy it's about the rest of the world
turning to a system for monetary
networks that's more energy efficient
because the current energy efficiency of
the fiat money world is horrible
yeah the fiat money is really a future
energy it's a promise to get future
energy energy that's
going to be produced by people that are
in debt with the system um so it's
monetizing the fiat system is monetizing
future energy-wise bitcoin is monetizing
uh current and past energy in the form
of surpluses all right because the fiat
money system is all about debt right we
live in the world that is a promise uh
to get energy in the future from the
depth right the global economy is
something like uh the debt to equity for
the world is like 300 percent
so the gdp the world is about 100
trillion dollars and there's more than
three hundred trillion dollars
so that gdp of the world is dedicated to
try to pay off that debt absolutely and
the the ease in which you can incur debt
is extraordinarily simple and easy to do
you just need to call up the central
bank and they'll give you all the money
you want it's zero percent interest rate
then they'll say go out there and spend
energy exactly to go pay it off bitcoin
is saying wait no
debt is not necessary in a situation
that's run entirely by
uh equity that is bitcoin is 100
equity you could say or is that is that
a misstatement how would you say about
that yeah equity is also a promise in
fact it's a promise on the future
dividends you know of the company so
it's also a promise so it's also some
some kind of uh future energy it's a
future energy of the company actually
equity is a share of that energy uh
whereas gold or bitcoin is really a
proof of energy so it's something that
proves that you have uh expanded or
utilized this energy you've monetized
the energy into a technology that um and
the purpose of that technology of money
is
to transfer energy from the past into
the present of a transaction uh and as
you said it can also translate energy
from from the future into the
transaction but the problem with uh
translating uh energy from the future is
that you can yeah the temptation is
great to monetize more energy than that
is going to be produced by by the
borrowers it's very tempting whereas if
it's past energy you can't fake it you
can't uh
make it up and uh play games with it so
that's very different it's a very
different view of the world it's a um
and and proof is and proof and promise
are two different things for for for
most people but they don't realize for
money it applies to money this
distinction applies to money when it
comes
uh from uh
when without money as bitcoin or as debt
right and you you mentioned some uh
thermite dynamics in there let's talk
about um does the use of energy make
bitcoin
anti-entropic money as opposed to being
let's say pro
entropy money you know we live in a
world of entropy everything is degrading
everything is falling apart um you know
gold is something that
doesn't have a lot of problems in terms
of entropy gold from a thousand years
ago can be still used today it's still
the same weight it's the an ounce of
gold a thousand years ago it's still an
ounce of gold and people still accept it
in terms of money
does bitcoin share this same attribute
because this is very hard for a lot of
people to wrap their minds around
because it's purely electronic it's
virtual very true i mean so how do you
bridge that gap and i mean if we're
saying it's anti-entropic like gold
how do you explain that
it's it's a tough one because uh gold is
perceived as something physical so you
can touch it in fact as you know atoms
are mostly void
over 99 of an atom is void so we are all
void we are in fact levitating over
these seeds because we are not touching
it the atoms are just
showing off on a tangent there buddy
we're levitating on the seat we're not
we're not here it's all void when you
have a piece of gold in your in your
hand you are not actually touching it
just uh it's just something uh that's
sitting on your hand but um you you've
taken the orange pill
and you're deep in the rabbit hole i i'm
deeply
just saying
for 10 years
[Laughter]
so information is perceived as abstract
and and intangible whereas it's of the
same nature as as
you know your dna is information atoms
are also information entropy is very uh
entropy is about energy i also because
as you know entropy to describe entropy
for for the listeners is uh let's say
it's the owner's manual of of your
ser of your universe you know and when i
get the owner's manual i
reduce my entropy i reduce my
uncertainty around about my surroundings
um so that's energy because because i
have reduced this uncertainty i will
save energy into for instance uh you
know building a piece of furniture if
you get uh the the the plan for this uh
piece of furniture you will spend less
energy building the piece of furniture
all right let's take this
um bit here and bitcoin is the same you
save energy using bitcoin so it's
equivalent to energy just like gold but
um
it's going through the entropy and
entropies it's an even more abstract
notion as energy energy is abstract but
entropy is even more abstract for most
people
in fact some scientists have trouble
defining entropy uh you could say it's
uh
information is negative entropy so but
that's not helping
right okay so continuing with this idea
here you also speak about a concept
avalanche and so in the physical world
and in the digital world the systems
become
a lopsided let's say systems asymmetric
risks
develop into crashes in the financial
markets
you know one snowflake hits the side of
a mountain and it's too much and it
starts an avalanche and so this is
something that's part of this physical
and non-physical world that exists both
digitally and in the physical world this
the the need to make equilibrium between
systems i guess that goes back to
thermodynamics in some way so
uh in the case of bitcoin um it almost
seems uh pierre that
bitcoin possesses attributes of let's
call spontaneous order that would be
something that's anti-entropic that's
the third law of thermodynamics is we're
all open systems and bitcoin is an open
system so as such it's self-organizing
so it will reduce its entropy to
maximize the flow energy through it so
that's exactly what we do as as living
beings we minimize our entropy so the
flow of energy that's going through us
is maximized that's the third law of
thermodynamics
and as a result um we are not in a
stable equilibrium there is no such
thing as a stable
equilibrium in in real life um it's to
take the image of a flag you know the
flag is is kept uh floating through
because the wind is going through it if
if there is no wind the fly will we
collapse it's the same for for open
systems like
living beings and societies and
civilizations right got to hold it there
carry over to a second segment thanks so
much pierre nozza
and that's going to do it for this
edition of kaiser report with me max
kaiser and stacey herbert i want to
thank our guest pierre noiza until next
time bye y'all
you